你即將看到的內容
會刷新你整個股市觀
讓你震驚自己啊
你要知道
世界上有一群人
他們研究股票的方式
和大部分投資人
完全不一樣
他們不研究公司的財務狀況
也不研究任何的數學公式跟指標
甚至不太在乎價格漲到哪裡
他們最在乎的只有一件事
時間
當所有專家都在告訴你
不要預測整個股價的高低點時
他們卻在自力研究股價什麼時候
最容易發生轉折
他們讓你知道你什麼時候買股票可以買在低點
什麼時候賣股票可以賣在高點
更離譜的是
這群人居然真的發現股市存在著一種隱藏的時間秩序
很多重要的高點和低點都不是隨機出現的
他們會按照某種週期不斷地重複發生
這套理論有一個很特別的名字叫做三角洲理論
今天這部影片
我想帶你認識這套在投資圈充滿神秘色彩的理論
他到底在研究什麼
為什麼認為漲點存在固定的週期
為什麼2026到2027年台股將非常危險
最重要的是使用這套理論
抓到股票的高地點的四個步驟
我敢跟你保證
當你看完這部影片
你看待股票的方式
會和過去完全不一樣
因為你將發現金融市場
有史以來最重大的秘密
我是小王子
20年股票實戰交易員
靠股票當沖跟波段
連續5年獲利破千萬
我會用你聽得懂的語言幫你看透股市裡沒有人願意說出的底層邏輯三角洲理論最初是有一個人發現的他叫吉姆·史洛文他花了很多年的時間研究股市的這套規律
最終整理出完整的理論架構
他後來把這套理論賣給一個知名的買家
叫做威爾斯·威爾德
也就是RSI指標發明者
他花了100萬美元
買下這套三角洲理論
在那個時代
100萬美元是個天文數字
威爾斯拿到理論之後
他們研究協會裡出現的叛徒
私下把這套理論公開返售
威爾斯經過深思熟慮後得出一個結論
與其讓這套理論繼續在黑市裡流傳
不如公開出書讓所有人都能平等的取得這些知識
於是三角洲理論就這樣出現在你我眼前
也就是說
三角洲理論本來是一個不開被公開的秘密
而你很快就會知道為什麼威爾斯本人不希望公開
接下來我們就來公開這個秘密
我先問你一個問題
你认为股价的涨跌是有秩序的吗?
什么叫做有秩序?
假如股价在8月7号出现高点
每过一个月
9月7号
10月7号
11月7号
也应该要出现高点
这就是秩序
所有人都会告诉你
不可能
我们无法预测高低点
但三角洲理论完美的证明了
股价的涨跌是有秩序的
理论的逻辑是这样的
股市由人组成
而人的情绪和行为
并不是完全随机的
我们的生活节奏
消费习惯
投資情緒
都會受到時間週期的影響
最明顯的例子